the guy sitting next he's like have you
gone into nfts yet I said no did you
ever get into nfts I said no wait so
you're a YouTuber and you didn't get
into I said first of all I'm not a
YouTuber I'm a business guy I run
companies but no I never got into nfts
you know how much money people made in
nfts I'm clearly aware of the people who
made the money and I know the thousands
who lost a lot of money what's going to
happen long term I don't know if they
deliver on their utilities Etc it's a 97
nfts are wasted time anyways then he
talks about crypto how about Bitcoin how
about this how about that for me My
Philosophy is simple what I know a lot
about I comfortably invest in I will
gladly deploy five 10 million dollars on
baseball cards and not even Flinch
because I know what I'm buying